In principle, a list ranking is a scan.
The essential problem
is this data structure.
It just has a single entry point,
which is the head.
And the interface as we've
defined it leaves no
option to get other elements of the list
without traversing them one by one.
Now put another way,
I could ask you the question what
made scans on arrays easier?
Essentially, it was random access.
So what you need to do is you need
to take this list representation and
turn it on its head, so to speak.
Let's imagine a different way
to represent a linked list
based on what I'll call an array pool.
And this representation
has two features.
First, we'll find a way to
put the values in an array.
And secondly, we'll replace
the concept of a pointer, or
a next pointer,
with a next integer index.
Let's see how this works.
As an example, suppose I allocate
an array to hold the values.
Let's call this array V.
Now notice that our
input list has 12 nodes,
even though the array has 14 spaces.
So in general we'll let our array pool
representation be at least the size of
our input list.
Now below each node in the input list,
I've written an integer.
Each integer will be the position of
the corresponding value in the V array.
For example, a node with value zero
resides in position 13 of the V array.
So let's put it there.
As another example, let's take
the first node whose value is 1.
Its position is 12 so
let's put it there.
What about the second
node whose value is 1?
Well that's in position 10,
so we put it there.
You could of course go on and
on and maybe you should.
Mm, smells quizzy.
So that's our story for values,
but what about the next pointers?
For that, let's allocate another array,
call it capital N.
Now I've made the length the same
between N and V, so that for
every value,
there's a corresponding next pointer.
Now although I'm calling these pointers
what I'll put there is not a memory
address but
rather the index of the node.
For example look at this node.
It points to the node
whose position is 9.
So it's next pointer should also be 9.
For the two nodes whose value is 1
the successors are at positions 5 and
8, so we should put those
in capital N as well.
This array pool
representation is critical
because it give us a way to have
multiple entry points into the list.
To do a list ranking you still
have to walk the list somehow.
But at least we'll be able to do things
like data parallel operations because we
basically stored everything as arrays.